they don't know how to count me out
but they don't know how to count
seems like wendy williams is gearing up
for a major comeback
telling her fans don't count me out
after her talk show's demise
[Applause]
wendy looks happy and healthy while
teasing a new project called the wendy
experience she dropped the teaser on
instagram for what looks like a podcast
and let jay-z song reminder do the
talking
[Music]
no reminder needed of wendy's reputation
after 13 successful seasons of the wendy
williams show today is the final episode
of the wendy williams show
there is nobody
nobody like wendy williams
from her days on the radio to ruling
daytime talk for 13 seasons wendy earned
her title as the queen of all media
of course sheri shepard who guests
hosted her namesake show now has wendy's
old time slot as she gears up to launch
her own talk show sherry
as for wendy's talker it ended amid her
battle against various health issues
which caused her to take a step back
from the program before the final season
kicked off i'm really going to miss the
show
mr president
you know she's unique you know there's
no other
but now the media personality says she's
stepping into new territory last week
she sat in her iconic purple chair and
teased what's to come
wendy doing a show not a tv show
wendy set the record straight writing
it's a windy experience stay tuned we've
got a lot to talk about ask for
potential guests seems wendy's looking
to the real housewives of atlanta here
she is hanging with nene leakes and
marlo hampton teasing in the caption
ladies of atl which peach should i have
on the wendy experience first
we can't wait to see how this new
chapter in wendy's career plays out and
her personal life a source told et back
in june the 57 year old is open to
finding her soul mate after finalizing
her nasty divorce from ex kevin hunter
in 2020 quote
wendy wants to fall in love and knows
that's exactly what she deserves i don't
have time for a lot of foolishness wendy
we can't wait to experience what's next
they don't know how to count me out but
they don't know how to count
oh well
[Music]